c'est dégueulasse une émission honteuse
un outil précieux ils ont balancé à la
police
c'est pas la tradition la télévision
publique de se mettre au service de la
police
personne n'aurait à gagner à ce que pour
chacun le journalisme puisse se
transformer en dénonciateur et en
policier
[Musique]
le jour où l'émission est diffusée une
intervention de la police le reportage
est diffusé les méchants s'en vont
on est là pour informer on n'est pas là
pour dénoncer
je pense que la télévision ne sera pas
un auxiliaire de justice ou de police
mais ce sera un outil au service de
l'enquête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la télévision au service de la police
des émissions qui collaborent avec la
justice utiliser la puissance de feu du
média dominant pour faire avancer des
enquêtes dans l'impasse retrouver des
personnes disparues ou tenter
d'appréhender des criminels en fuite
l'eau judiciaire à la mise en scène
hollywoodienne qui cartonne depuis des
années partout dans le monde partout non
pas en France encore une exception
culturelle alors pourquoi ici la justice
spectacle n'a pas sa place et crée le
malaise et même le scandale comment
définir cette télévision télé vérités
téléservices télésivisme télé flics ou
télé choc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
San Francisco États-Unis l'homme que
vous voyez va tomber dans un piège ce
médecin est père de famille il a 44 ans
aujourd'hui il vient honorer un
rendez-vous galant qui l'a pris quelques
jours plus tôt sur Internet problème la
jeune fille est mineure mais c'est
exactement ce qu'il vient chercher
bienvenue sur MSNBC vous regardez tout
catch Predator traduisez comment
attraper un prédateur une version trash
de surprise surprise le principe
provoquer des présumés délinquants
sexuel sur internet et les attirer dans
une maison truffée de caméra cachée
ils se font passer pour des enfants
pour des enfants plutôt qui ont plutôt
14 15 ans et les comédiennes qu'ils
embauchent là-dessus sont plutôt en
mini-jupe attente de le prédateur le dit
prédateurs dans un appartement on va
prendre douche et c'est l'animateur
vedette qui est derrière le rideau et
qui dit bonjour vous êtes sur 4 jours
Predator vous avez dit ça vous êtes là
pourquoi vous êtes un pédophile soit il
tombe dans les pommes soit il prend un
coup de Taser et s'il décide d'ouvrir la
porte il y a toujours une équipe du FBI
qui n'arrête derrière
des arrestations musclées pour un
programme spectaculaire loin des règles
de la morale et du droit français
c'est de la provocation en fait
on provoque quelqu'un et puis d'un seul
coup on le montre au public on le
dévoile on le met sous l'oeil des
caméras alors humainement c'est
dégueulasse
c'est pour moi
une émission honteuse honteuse dans le
sens où c'est du spectacle c'est pas de
l'info c'est pas fait par des
journalistes c'est fait par une
programme de télévision
présumé coupable ici la télévision
provoque le crime le puni et le juge
instantanément un forfait tout en un
dans notre métier dans mon métier on a
pas le droit de faire de la provocation
elle est interdite à part quelques cas
très limités en matière de stupe etc
mais de manière générale on n'a pas le
droit de faire de la provocation on
constate la commission de crime de
délits etc mais on peut pas encourager à
la Commission de délits
Predator du spectacle profit de
l'audience 7 millions de téléspectateurs
en moyenne quatre ans d'existence et une
vingtaine de pédophiles jugés
et c'est la violence de la rencontre et
la violence de la mise en image et de
l'arrestation souvent très physique et
tout ça qui fait qui a fait le succès de
ça et voilà c'est une émission qui s'est
arrêtée heureusement qui n'existera
jamais en France heureusement
en France pas de catch le Predator la
télévision est soumise à des règles
précises il est très difficile de
marcher sur les plates bandes du pouvoir
judiciaire
[Musique]
Yvan Aubé et juriste spécialisé dans
l'audiovisuel il a longtemps travaillé
au service juridique de TF1 et connaît
sur le bout des doigts les limites qu’un
programme de télévision ne peut pas
dépasser alors en France le grand
principe c'est que chaque diffuseur m'a
retenu à respecter évidemment les lois
générales qui s'appliquent de toute
façon à tous que son code pénal que sont
le code de procédure pénal et il y a
aussi un aspect réglementaire qui est
que chaque personne qui dans ce pays
possède le droit des maîtres de la
télévision à en contrepartie des
engagements à l'égard d'une autorité de
régulation qui est le Conseil supérieur
de visuel je vous donne le droit
d'émettre
mais en contrepartie merci de respecter
un grand nombre de principes
qui sont en vigueur dans notre société
dans une démocratie etc etc
le respect de la présomption d'innocence
du secret de l'instruction et de la vie
privée trois règles de base très
françaises
[Musique]
il y a rien dans ces textes qui est de
nature particulièrement scandaleux mais
il est vrai que ça délimite les choses
de manière extrêmement précise sur ce
qui est possible de faire en télévision
la télévision française a donc peu de
latitude pour venir empiéter sur le
territoire de la justice pourtant au
début des années 90 elle se lance dans
le grand bain de l'appel à témoins en
s'abritant derrière la panne judiciaire
de certaines affaires et réactive ainsi
l'enquête une vraie révolution dans le
PAF après avoir lancé perdu de vue en
1991 basé sur la recherche de personnes
disparues TF1 monte encore d'un cran
deux ans plus tard avec témoin numéro 1
à la télévision d'une nouvelle forme
d'émission témoin numéro 1 qui va voir
le jour juste après ce journal et que
nous présente tout de suite Thomas
Hugues et Marie Laure Bonn
dernier préparatif cet après-midi pour
une émission d'un nouveau genre avec
témoin numéro 1 pour la première fois la
télévision va diffuser en direct des
appels à témoins objectif avoué aider la
justice à trouver la solution d'affaires
criminelle compliquée perdu de vue et
témoin numéro 1 sont animés par Jacques
Pradel elle reproduisent le même schéma
appel à témoin en direct reconstitution
plus vrai que nature dramatisation de la
recherche des personnes disparues
émotion des retrouvailles bref tous les
ingrédients nécessaires un immense
succès immédiat entre 7 et 9 millions
d'acros chaque semaine quasiment un
téléspectateur sur deux
[Musique]
et pourtant dès le début la polémique
fait rage jamais deux concepts de
télévision n'avaient été autant contesté
voyeurisme et risque de transformer le
téléspectateur en indicateurs de police
[Musique]
moi je peux vous dire ce soir que 1 nous
ne rendrons pas la justice à l'antenne
que 2 nous mènerons pas dans quelques
criminelle et que 3 nous nous bornerons
mais c'est déjà très important et c'est
effectivement une première en France à
mettre les moyens de télévision au
service du public pour que nous
puissions ensemble éventuellement
trouver des informations nouvelles qui
feront avancer la justice faire avancer
la justice c'est ce que perdu de vue a
réussi à faire sur l'un des dossiers
criminels les plus médiatisés de ces 30
dernières années
Pascal brognot était à l'époque
directrice des magazines et des
documentaires de TF1 retour sur le coup
d'éclat de l'émission
[Musique]
il y a une affaire sur laquelle perdu de
vue a passé plus de deux ans deux ans et
demi avec plusieurs journalistes qu'elle
a fait Émile Louis
[Musique]
on avait été mis en relation avec une
famille un couple dont la fille qui
avait à ce moment-là 22 ou 23 ans avait
disparu donc on s'est mis à enquêter sur
cette disparition puis en même temps
qu'on a trouvé des éléments sur cette
disparition on a trouvé une deuxième
fille dans les mêmes conditions puis
après une troisième et puis 4 5 6
familles quand on les contacts qui nous
disent oui que leur leur fille a disparu
et puis on arrive à 9 10 ce qui fait que
l'émission a fait un bazar pas possible
on a continué à enquêter et enfin la
justice s'est emparée du dossier
sérieusement et quatre ans plus tard
Émile Louis
a été a été emprisonné a été saisi
emprisonné
[Musique]
Émile Louis sera condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour le viol et
le meurtre de cette jeune femme ce sont
les familles des victimes qui en
sollicitant les missions perdues de vue
on fait avancer un dossier que la
justice a longtemps refusé de traiter
c'est vrai que l'émission a montré elle
a une une carence dans dans à la fois la
police et la justice qui étaient enfin
ils sont très bien amis mais qui n'était
pas flatteuse si vous voulez les
lenteurs et les ratés de la justice
perdus de vue appuie là où ça fait mal
ce sont des émissions qui
d'une certaine façon prenait le relais
d'institution française c'est-à-dire
qu'elle prenait le relais de la justice
le relais de la police en tout cas elle
faisait un travail parallèle assez c'est
deux institutions
et souvent dans la charnement que nous
mettions avec des très bons enquêteurs à
trouver des pistes pour retrouver des
gens finalement on retrouvait des choses
que ni les gens d'armes ni la police
n'avait trouvé donc forcément ils
étaient pas contents
il la détient c'est tout il a été
quelque part c'est ralent c'est rageant
parce qu'il était plus malin que nous et
ça c'est énervant de savoir ça c'est
vrai que c'est c'est difficile c'est
difficile à accepter
se dire quand même comment est-ce qu'il
a pu comment est-ce qu'il peut savoir ça
alors que moi je suis pas arrivé avec
les moyens dont je dispose ça c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas été bon c'est qu'il
a été meilleur que nous dans les années
la télévision devient donc le dernier
recours des familles désespérées par des
enquêtes dans l'impasse et Jacques
Pradel le symbole de l'espoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Besançon 20 octobre 1996 Virginie
Raymond 16 ans est assassiné à son
domicile de 14 coups de couteau un crime
audio sans mobile et sans témoin une
enquête qui piétine une instruction
interminable et infructueuse
[Musique]
en 1993 soit 6 ans après les faits le
dossier est repris par une jeune juge
d'instruction anne-carron d'église
initialement réticente à l'idée de
lancer un appel à témoin par voie de
télévision dans l'émission témoin numéro
1 elle finit par céder sous la pression
des parents inconsolables
donc avec les enquêteurs nous avons fait
le point sur le dossier nous avons pris
tous les éléments du dossier pour
constater que nous étions dans une
impasse et face à une impasse
face à des parents qui ont le souhait
que l'enquête se poursuive on leur donne
toutes les chances de pouvoir au moins
avoir un certain nombre d'éléments qui
font avancer les choses
je me suis dit qu'effectivement il
pouvait être important de faire un appel
à témoin comme nous le faisons nous les
magistrats
la justice qui s'en remet à la
télévision une première en France
pour les parents de la jeune victime et
Guy Garnache enquêteurs sur le dossier
Raymond l'incapacité des institutions à
résoudre cette affaire justifier le
recours à l'émission
c'est sûr qu'utilisais à télévision
c'est un élément ça me paraît ça me
paraît quelque chose d'intéressant on
peut difficilement dire s'adresser aux
parents et leur dire écoutez non c'est
pas notre c'est pas notre système de
fonctionner j'ai estimé qu'effectivement
ça pouvait être une chance de relancer
l'enquête à condition que l'on pose un
certain nombre de critères à notre
intervention que l'on réquisitionne la
chaîne et en tout cas cette émission
spécifique que l'on contrôle les images
qui allait être diffusées parce que je
vous rappelle que dans une instruction
nous sommes tenues au secret de
l'instruction donc on ne peut pas
diffuser n'importe comment et dans
n'importe quelle condition ni des images
ni des éléments propres à l'enquête donc
il fallait que nous contrôlions ce qui
était diffusé et ensuite sur le plateau
il fallait évidemment que l'on soit bien
d'accord et avec les producteurs de
l'émission et avec le présentateur pour
que les choses soient suffisamment
cadrées et dernier élément pour que tous
les éléments d'information que nous
aurions à travailler
à l'issue des propos qu'on pourrait
tenir à l'antenne soit maîtriser
exclusivement par les enquêteurs contre
vents et marées anne-carron d'église
décide donc de participer en direct à
l'émission témoin numéro 1 à l'époque
ces confrères du Syndicat national de la
magistrature crie au scandale et demande
même l'interdiction de la diffusion du
programme c'est extrêmement critiqué
c'est à dire que j'ai eu des avis de
collègues qui étaient extrêmement
négatif d'abord parce que c'était une
prise de risque aller faire une émission
en direct sur un dossier en cours c'est
toujours une prise de risque d'autre
part l'émission en elle-même était
critiquée parce que voyeuriste parce que
allant sur des plates bandes qui
n'étaient pas nécessairement des plates
bandes tout à fait balisées et donc avec
des objectifs journalistiques qui
n'étaient pas nécessairement des
objectifs d'enquête
avec entre guillemets une prise de
tâches des familles et de leurs douleurs
parce qu'on pouvait imaginer à d'autres
faim
donc voilà je n'ai absolument pas été
soutenu dans cette démarche et bien au
contraire
mais les reconstitutions filmées comme
des réalités chauds tranchent souvent
avec la dignité affichée par les parents
des victimes sont-elles là pour aider la
justice ou pour entretenir un suspense
malsain pour Monsieur et Madame Raymond
les parents de Virginie le débat est
tout simplement ailleurs toute façon il
leur faut leur faut du grain bon ça
notre malheur mais nous on regardait pas
à ça de ce qu'on voulait c'est que ça
nous aide oui on n'a pas pris ça
le reste
on voulait que ça nous aide que ça nous
apporte quelque chose que notre fille
soit pas été on sache pourquoi elle est
morte déjà
en dépit de quelques pistes relancées
juste après la diffusion l'émission ne
parviendra malheureusement pas à
résoudre le meurtre de la jeune Virginie
Raymond pourtant à l'époque l'espoir des
familles de victimes est immense mais
cela ne suffit pas à stopper la vague de
contestation les appels à témoin sont la
cible principale des détracteurs du
programme et un vilain fantôme resurgit
du passé
c'était en France on avait très sensible
sur les questions de délation et tout
d'un coup voilà le mot était devenu à la
mode c'est une émission où on incite à
la délation ou va la France j'ai eu des
critiques terribles absolument terrible
pour Patrick Menet producteur de témoin
numéro 1 la critique n'est pourtant pas
fondée de délation ce qui à mon avis n'a
aucun sens parce que le témoignage c'est
pas de la délation la justice le civisme
ça repose sur le témoignage le
témoignage c'est même une obligation une
obligation légale donc tout ce débat a
été a été pollué par par ce mot de
délation
ce n'est pas de la délation c'est des
témoignages
c'est aider la justice
très utile indispensable même c'est
l'adénation amène à révéler des choses
plus ou moins vraies éventuellement
malsaine éventuellement complètement
fausse et donc peu tout à fait induit
des comportements qui sont qui peuvent
être gravissime
l'appel à témoin c'est autre chose c'est
on appelle des personnes qui ont pu
constater constaté d'elle-même et un
certain nombre de choses que jusqu'à
présent elles n'ont pas voulu divulguer
ou pas divulguer parce qu'elles
ignoraient que ça pouvait avoir une
importance pour l'enquête et le témoin
pour un enquêteur c'est celui là
depuis la France de Vichy on préfère le
secret c'est sur cet épisode non digéré
de notre passé récent que Fabien Jobard
sociologue s'appuie pour tenter
d'expliquer les réactions épidermiques
de la critique en France
il y a des épisodes
traumatique parce que je pense que la
société française
n'a sans doute pas réglé tout ses
problèmes à son égard c'est l'épisode de
du régime de Vichy
et de la déportation des Juifs qui
s'appuyait en partie
sur la bonne volonté des citoyens à
dénoncer son voisin pourvu qu'il fut
juif
ou pas l'amalgame délation témoignage
n'est pas le seul argument des opposants
à ce genre de programme télévisé autre
effet repoussoir à l'époque ces
émissions sont diffusées sur TF1
télévision etendarmes des chaînes
privées dont commercial une
contradiction au regard de la mission de
service public que ce sont fixés ces
producteurs
le fait et en soi sur une télévision
privée TF1 effectivement ça n'a pas
facilité c'est un peu faussé le débat je
pense que une même émission sur France
Télévisions France 2 France 3 à l'époque
aurait été beaucoup mieux perçu parce
que on aurait vraiment dès le départ eu
cette marque de service public
l'objectif premier de TF1 c'était pas
nécessairement qu'on pourrait aux
enquêtes ça a été d'imaginer la
production d'une émission qui pouvait
être grand public bon je crois qu'il
faut qu'on parle des choses telles
qu'elles sont et à partir de là nous
sommes évidemment dans des finalités
très différentes
après si saisons d'un immense succès
pour perdre de vue le programme s'arrête
en avril 1997 quelques mois seulement
après l'interruption de témoin numéro 1
officiellement pour cause d'usure Pascal
Brugnot l'ancienne directrice des
magazines de la chaîne à une toute autre
interprétation il se trouve que les
annonceurs trouvaient que dans le fond
la détresse humaine même si souvent ça
se termine bien le fait de montrer des
gens qui qui pouvaient éventuellement
pleurer enfin l'émission n'était pas
assez glamour pour leur goût donc les
annonceurs
la bouteille et donc sur une chaîne
commerciale quand ils annonceurs boudes
le programme disparaît
la logique implacable du marché malgré
des audiences béton perdu de vue et
témoins numéro 1 ne survivent pas au
diktat des annonceurs difficiles à
l'heure de croire à la mission de
service public que s'était fixée TF1 un
cas unique en Europe
et dans tous les pays du monde cette
émission existe depuis 20 ans 25 ans et
continue à exister notamment en
Angleterre notamment en Italie en
Espagne en Allemagne et toutes ces
émissions sont diffusées dans ces autres
pays sur des chaînes service public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
participer activement aux enquêtes est
ici un acte civique et la police n'est
pas un ennemi en Grande-Bretagne rien de
choquant a dénoncé son voisin la
connaissance
est très insérée dans son corps social
dans sa communauté et on vient lui
rapporter des faits rapporter des
informations
à ciel ouvert et c'est tout à fait
légitime parce que ça participe de à la
bonne santé de la community du voisinage
en France notre rapport à la police est
totalement inversé et c'est Gérard
Gachet porte-parole du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui en fait la constatation
le fait pour la population de travailler
avec des services de police ou de
gendarmerie
chez nous il y a plus de réticences
on est plus facilement en France du côté
de guignols que du côté du gendarme vous
voyez le gouffre qui s'éteint ici
la conception qu'on a en Angleterre de
la police mais au-delà évidemment de
l'état de la puissance publique de celle
qu'on a qu'on a en France donc a priori
en tout cas
en France je ne crois pas que ces
émissions de télévision soient vraiment
le relais d'une tradition d'une
tradition ancienne et c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles ces émissions là ne marchent
pas en France à la différence de la
Grande-Bretagne ou des Pays-Bas
et bien évidemment aux États-Unis aussi
[Musique]
les programmes allemands xy et anglais
crime watch on fait des petits
America's Most Wanted comprenez l'homme
le plus recherché d’amérique mais ici
chez l'Oncle Sam on voit tout en très
grand
l'émission est mise à l'antenne en 1988
sur la chaîne Fox elle est animée par
John Wolf devenu une véritable star du
petit écran
il s'est lancé dans l'aventure après
avoir perdu son fils Adam six ans
assassiné dans des conditions atroces
depuis John Wolf joue au chasseur de
primes et pour retrouver les bandits ses
avis de recherche sont des plus racoleur
écoutez-moi ce malade est vraiment
dangereux pour l'instant il utilise ce
flingue pour s'amuser mais un jour il va
blesser ou même tuer quelqu'un
le show diffusé empruntime tous les
samedis soirs et produit par la Century
Fox le plus grand studio de cinéma
hollywoodien la police a une image
qu'elle cultive là-bas qui fait partie
du signe de l'histoire du cinéma
américain de l'histoire des séries
télévisées américaines ils sont
eux-mêmes tout le temps dans un film
déjà il y a une vraie différence de
culture entre culture américaine et
culture française sur l'image des
policiers la réalité c'est que les
genèses de ces systèmes juridiques sont
différentes que les populations sont
différentes il y a des logiques
différentes et qui aboutissent à une
compatibilité entre justice police et
médias qui est extrêmement différente
c'est clair
le 6 mars 2010 et la fêté son millième
numéro en direct de la Maison Blanche
avec ce soir là un invité de marque et
un beau bilan plus de 1000 arrestations
et 43 enfants enlevés rendus à leurs
parents
ici plus que partout ailleurs la télé se
substitue à la police le téléspectateur
est ouvertement un flic potentiel et
l'émission en auxiliaire revendiquées du
FBI totalement inimaginable en France
je dirais que le titre même de
l'émission américaine il est déjà contre
nature il violerait le principe même que
les chaînes françaises sont tenues
respectées et qui sont écrits dans le
code de procédure pénale donc de
présenter quelqu'un comme étant la plus
recherchée de France je vois très mal
comment ça peut être de nature à la
laisser dans une perception générale
qu'elle serait éventuellement innocente
la présomption d'innocence bafouée par
America's Most Wanted mais pourtant
qu’une des nombreuses règles à respecter
en France pour mettre à l'antenne une
émission qui travaillerait main dans la
main avec les ministères concernés la
justice et l'intérieur
il faut que l'émission ne gêne pas
l'enquête or elle peut la gêner de deux
façons soit en cherchant à mettre en
scène un scénariser des éléments de
l'enquête ce qui naturelle puisque pour
une télévision il faut une mise en scène
il faut du spectacle il faut de l'image
la télévision elle a besoin de générer
de l'émotion et donc elle fait elle
utilise la mise en scène pour pour faire
ça c'est tout à fait classique et enfin
bien sûr il y a un certain nombre de
règles à respecter il y a respecté le
secret de l'instruction ce qui est aussi
difficilement compatible parfois avec
une mise en scène télévisée il y a à
respecter la mémoire ou la personnalité
des victimes bien entendu et à respecter
la présomption d'innocence des personnes
qui pourraient être mises en cause donc
tout ça fait un ensemble de règles qui
peut expliquer aussi la rareté de ce
genre d'émission
[Applaudissements]
trop risqué et trop contraignante les
émissions d'appels à témoin ont donc
complètement disparu du paysage
audiovisuel français depuis plus de 10
ans jusqu'à ce jour de l'automne 2005
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lorsque vous entendrez cette sirène et
que vous verrez ce message cela signifie
que le ministère de la Justice a lancé
le dispositif d'urgence pour retrouver
un enfant enlevé
l'alerte enlèvement est un dispositif
dont la force réside dans sa capacité à
toucher la population la plus large dans
un délai très court en d'autres termes
incités à témoigner pour retrouver des
enfants disparus les médias est donc la
télévision deviennent l'arme principale
de la visibilité du message pour la
première fois en France tout le monde
s'accorde sur le bien-fondé de l'appel à
témoin
ce qui nous paraît extrêmement naturel
est une véritable révolution dans
l'illustration quand aujourd'hui un
enfant dans des conditions très
particulières avec des critères
extrêmement précis est identifié comme
ayant fait l'objet d'un enlèvement vous
avez le ministère de la Justice je dis
bien et lui seul qui active un
dispositif qui consiste à faire que tous
les médias
télévision radio français vont diffuser
ce sont engagés à diffuser ce message
[Applaudissements]
toutes les grandes chaînes françaises
sont engagées par l'accord qu'ils ont
signé avec le ministère de la Justice
jamais encore en France un tel consensus
entre télévisions et institution
judiciaire n'avait été trouvé sans que
personne n'y trouve rien à redire Alerte
Enlèvement un modèle importé des
États-Unis le pays où l'appel à témoin
est roi
[Musique]
pour Guillaume Didier porte-parole du
ministère de la Justice il n'y a aucun
doute sur les bénéfices que les
enquêteurs peuvent tirer de la puissance
de feu de la télévision
le bilan est exceptionnel parce qu'il a
été déclenché à 9 reprises et à chaque
fois le plan attendez a démontré son
efficacité son utilité pour les
enquêteurs et pour l'enquête
[Applaudissements]
un enfant a été enlevé
toutes les précautions sont prises pour
que l'appel à témoin ne se transforme
pas en chasse à l'homme c'est ce que
tient à préciser le commissaire Frédéric
Malon chef de l'Office central pour la
répression de la violence aux personnes
dans les cas précis de l'Alerte
Enlèvement on ne demande pas aux
citoyens de se substituer aux policier
on lui demande simplement d'apporter son
témoignage et bien spécifier dans le
message qui est diffusé de ne pas
intervenir soi-même mais d'appeler la
police n'agissez pas seul composé le
numéro de téléphone qui vous sera
communiqué si et seulement si vous
disposez d'informations dans le cas d'un
déclenchement du premier enlèvement la
télévision devient un outil précieux
pour les enquêteurs je ne sais pas si on
peut dire que c'est un auxiliaire de la
police en tout cas c'est un outil
précieux pour les enquêteurs de la
police de la gendarmerie ou pour les
magistrats
mais hors ce dispositif particulier les
programmes d'appels à témoins sont
absents des antennes françaises ce qui
n'empêche pas les initiatives de se
multiplier comme celle qui a tenté Alain
boulet président de l'apaise l'aide aux
parents d'enfants victimes son
association véritable centre
opérationnel pour l'aide à la recherche
d'enfants disparus a conçu et fabriqué
un programme court dans l'espoir de
pouvoir être diffusé pour pouvoir
diffuser les photos des enfants disparus
au plus grand nombre et que tout le
monde puisse le voir on a bien sûr pensé
à la télévision et je me suis approché
d'abord d'une société de production qui
nous a aidé à faire un pilote que l'on a
montré à la Chancellerie que l'on a
montré au mystère de l'intérieur et on a
eu un accord pour que ces appels à
témoins puissent passer dans le cadre
des enquêtes avec même l'accord du juge
d'instruction
et des noix à retrouver Mathieu disparus
à Embrun dans les Hautes-Alpes en 2004
il avait 17 ans on s'est rapproché des
chaînes de télévision et c'est là où on
a des chanté puisque on n'a pas obtenu
de pouvoir faire passer ces spots à la
télévision et il est dommage que les
chaînes soient un petit peu frileux
vis-à-vis de ce genre d'émission
alors à qui la faute obstruction des
ministères concernés ou réel frilosité
des diffuseurs
si ça existe peu ce n'est pas du fait du
ministère de l'Intérieur puisque chez
nous il n'y a pas d'opposition de
principe à ce type d'émission on peut
penser aussi qu'il y a des hésitations
des chaînes parce que pour qu'une
émission de ce genre fonctionne
d'appels à témoin il faut qu'il y a à la
fois une un grand public qui puisse être
touché et une heure de grande écoute
donc ça veut dire que seuls des grandes
chaînes
nationales si possible en prime time
peuvent lancer ce type d'émission a
priori or ça représente pour elle aussi
un risque maximal en termes d'audience
donc peut-être que elle juge que
actuellement elle ne peuvent pas ou ne
doivent pas prendre ce risque maximal
ne serait-ce alors qu'une histoire
d'audience donc de gros sous il y a une
frilosité des chaînes mais qui n'est pas
du tout au désintérêt pour le programme
mais c'est je pense c'est de la de la
crainte de l'insécurité juridique
justement sur la diffusabilité du
programme donc vous n'aurez jamais un
diffuseur en France parce que pour avoir
touché sa très près qui ira sans avoir à
peu près des garanties sur le fait que
je le monte va passer crouler sur sa
tête un moment donné parce que quand
vous avez justement
le CSA le ministère de la Justice le
Syndicat national de la magistrature
j'en passe à des meilleurs où tout le
monde peut vous reprocher tout parce que
finalement tout ça est un peu subtil le
dosage la manière de le faire est-ce
qu'on est encore sur la ligne jaune ou
pas sur la ligne jaune tout ça étant
tellement délicat que il est il est un
petit peu préférable pour un diffuseur
de surtout ne rien faire
mais boosté par le succès total de
l'Alerte Enlèvement qui a aiguisé les
appétits des producteurs certains
programmes sur TF1 et France 2 semblent
renouer avec l'appel à témoin
[Musique]
la première d'entre elles non élucidé
fait son apparition sur France 2 à
l'automne 2008 l'émission revient sur
des affaires classées loin très loin des
enquêtes en cours traitées dans les
choses américaines chaque épisode
raconte une affaire non résolue en
revenant en détail sur toutes les zones
d'ombre des dossiers le producteur
Arnaud Poivre d'Arvor et son complice
l'ancien patron du SRP j de Versailles
Jean-Marc Bloch permettent ainsi aux
téléspectateurs de mettre leur pas dans
ceux des enquêteurs
c'est l'affaire ou plutôt les affaires
non élucidés les plus anciennes et les
plus énigmatiques de l'histoire de la PJ
parisienne
avec nonélucidés Arnaud Poivre d'Arvor
et Jean-Marc Bloch franchissent enfin le
Rubicon
je crois que ce qui nous anime tous les
deux Jean-Marc sur le nom du site c'est
que c'est pour ça que je crois que tu as
accepté aussi de faire cette émission
c'est que au fond de nous pas la
prétention avec cette émission de
résoudre l'affaire directement en
revanche d'apporter de nouveaux éléments
de nouveaux éclairages je sais que sur
une affaire que l'on a traité qui date
d'il y a plus de 20 ans il y a eu un
nouveau témoin qui s'est présenté au
service de police donc ça prouve que ça
prouve que ça fait bouger les bouger les
lignes on est dans un monde moins fermé
la police et la justice ce sont des
enfermés désincarcérés la télé peu
apporter c'est évident que la télé qui
est un outil de communication
extraordinaire interne est aussi
d'ailleurs peut permettre à des à des
gens de se réveiller de raconter des
choses qui n'ont pas osé raconter une
époque ou qui n'osait pas dire
l'objectif de non élucider diffuser en
seconde partie de soirée et finalement
le même que celui affiché par Jacques
Pradel dans les années 90 trouver de
nouveaux témoins sur de vieux dossiers
pour Nathalie darigan directrice des
magazines de société à France
Télévisions c'est le discours qui a
changé la télévision ne se met plus au
service de la police mais se positionne
désormais du côté des victimes
[Musique]
dans une collectionées évidemment
complètement dans une mission de service
public c'est-à-dire vraiment au service
la des familles qui sont dans la
souffrance on est et qui sont dans
l'attente que l'enquête puisse être
relancée qui est de nouvelles pistes qui
puissent être trouvées
chaque année en France plus de 48 000
enfants disparaissent
du coup quelques mois plus tard TF1
décide à son tour de tenter l'aventure
avec disparition un nouveau magazine
d'enquête sur les personnes disparues
ministère magistrats services de police
et de gendarmerie tout son décidé de
jouer car sur table pour que la
médiatisation des affaires soit utile
aux enquêtes
c'est ce que nous explique Pierre
Antoine cAPTON le coproducteur de
l'émission avec le plan Alerte
Enlèvement qui a été lancé il y a
quelques années on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait un vrai service sort de
service public pour les enlèvements
d'enfants qui sont de plus amplement
nombreux en France chaque année et on
s'est dit qu'on pouvait réussir
aujourd'hui à réimposer à la télévision
une émission d'appel à témoin où on
pouvait revenir sur des cas
éventuellement faire avancer des
affaires
trois affaires nous intéressent ce soir
première affaire celle des Nice
coca-cure 5 ans enlevé devant son
domicile à Roubaix en août 2016 les
années 80 encore une fois c'était du
show out sur toutes les chaînes de télé
perdu du témoin numéro 1 tout est
possible on pouvait tous permettre
aujourd'hui on va dire que sur TF1 il y
a plus de programme
sulfureux comme ça pour exister donc on
essaye d'amener du sens dans tout ce
qu'on fait
et les chaînes les chaînes ont un peu
peur en termes de communication de
repartir sur des programmes sulfureux
pour moi aujourd'hui l'appel à témoin la
télévision pour les personnes disparues
il y a rien de sulfureux il y a rien de
dangereux tout dépend de la façon dont
on le fait
en France entre les années 90 et
aujourd'hui les mentalités ont
considérablement évolué même si les
cadres juridiques sont beaucoup plus
strictes que dans les pays anglo-saxons
les émissions d'appels à témoin refont
surface timidement mais le ton a changé
oublier les mines compatissantes de
Jacques Pradel aujourd'hui la télévision
a construit une écriture plus en phase
avec les impératifs de la justice ce qui
laisse entrevoir un avenir commun
radieux on note depuis quelques années
une vraie communauté d'esprit entre les
journalistes les producteurs de
télévision les grandes chaînes de
télévision et finalement le milieu
judiciaire jusqu'à chaque fois que les
émissions comme celle-là ça c'est
toujours fait avec l'accord la
coopération de la justice qu'il y a
trouvé elle aussi son intérêt le vrai
but à mon avis deux heures d’émission
c'est de s'imposer emprime sur une
grande chaîne que ça soit tF1 France
Télévisions ou M6 voilà on en a besoin
ça existe à l'étranger ça marche partout
c'est le traitement qu'on va le donner
et si on enlève le côté chaud en plateau
qui peut être un peu voilà néfaste à ce
type de programme à mon avis on pourra
imaginer un disparition en prime time on
dirait sur une chaîne comme TF1 c'est le
but du jeu je pense que il y a des
choses des belles choses à construire
dans l'avenir et de manière
fine pleine de tactes d'intelligence
pour faire
œuvre de justice au final grâce à la
télévision
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un retour timide de la télévision dans
le monde de la justice les liens entre
la police et les journalistes des
questions qui n'agitent pas vraiment le
landerneau de la presse jusqu'en cette
fin d'hiver 2010 coup sur coup et sur
les deux plus grandes chaînes de France
la diffusion de deux reportages va
ramener ces questions au centre des
débats
lundi 29 mars 2010 Tremblay-en-France en
Seine-Saint-Denis gros coup de filet de
la police un million d'euros en liquide
2 kg de cocaïne saisie et plusieurs
arrestations dans la cité du grand
ensemble très vite dans le quartier la
rumeur enfle cette attaque serait la
réponse des dealers un reportage sur le
trafic de drogue dans la cité du grand
ensemble diffusé lundi soir sur TF1
mardi 6 avril c'est au tour de France 2
de diffuser un reportage sur la
pédophilie dans l'émission Les Infiltrés
un journaliste enquête en caméra cachée
s'infiltre dans les réseaux et finit par
signaler les agissements de 23
délinquants sexuels présumés aux
autorités au cours de ce dernier
entretien jacquard me confie avoir
repéré deux nouvelles jeunes victimes
dont il compte abusé prochainement le
lendemain j'arrête les policiers
canadiens il sera interpellé après
enquête 40 jours plus tard
[Musique]
seul temps pour les journalistes la même
semaine en France un reportage sur le
trafic de stupéfiant un autre sur la
pédophilie des arrestations en pagaille
un immense boucan médiatique et une
question une seule les journalistes
sont-ils devenus des auxiliaires de
police
retour à Tremblay-en-France quelques
heures seulement avant la diffusion sur
TF1 d'un reportage intitulé mes voisins
sont des dealers dans le magazine
d'Emmanuel Chain haute définition la
police mène une vaste opération
antidrogue bilan 4 personnes en garde à
vue la concomitance du coup de filet et
de la diffusion du reportage crée un
mélange détenant une pure coïncidence
le jour où l'émission est diffusée une
intervention de la police
et donc évidemment peu exister un
soupçon qui est de dire ils ont balancé
à la police des infos
des propos confirmés par Yannick
d'agneau porte-parole du syndicat Unité
police
l'affaire de Tremblant en France c'est
pour nous pour nous selon nos
informations il n'y a pas eu du tout
confusion mélange des genres
une journaliste spécialisée dans
l'investigation traite
son reportage parallèlement à une
enquête de police judiciaire qui menée
par les effectifs du commissariat de
Villepinte
problème l'émission est enregistrée en
plateau quelques jours avant la
diffusion et l'intervention de la police
le reportage présenté par Emmanuel Chain
est enregistré tout est enregistré et
dans cette émission on voit le numéro 2
la police judiciaire de la préfecture de
police qui vient témoigner qui sur le
plateau on peut effectivement penser que
ce haut responsable à visionner le
reportage et peut-être qu'effectivement
il a déclenché une demandé qu'il les
interpellations ait lieu
préventivement de manière à ce qui
pourrait se passer je veux dire le
reportage est diffusé les méchants s'en
vont moi je répète clairement au cas
aucun moment nous leur avons donné
aucune information pas la moindre
information que nous avons même pris sur
nous de protéger nos sources de manière
évidentes dans le reportage mais aussi
en détruisant dans les disques durs les
rushs au cas où les perquisitions de la
police etc on les mettant à l'extérieur
dans un endroit que seul deux personnes
connaissent pour éviter que puisse avoir
accès bon voilà donc nous on a fait
notre boulot de manière totalement
également honnête
ce que met en lumière l'affaire de
Tremblay c'est le principe pour les
journalistes de la protection des sourds
la source c'est l'individu qui est à
l'origine même de l'information ou du
renseignement un principe indispensable
à la liberté d'expression qui permet au
journaliste de refuser face aux
autorités judiciaires de révéler
l'identité de cette personne
la protection des sources est absolument
essentielle
que c'est ce qui nous permet d'ailleurs
à les protéger par la loi du 4 janvier
seuls des motifs des impératifs d'ordre
public très importants peuvent porter
atteinte à cette possibilité de protéger
source sans obligation pour autant pour
le journalisme de les révéler donc
c'était pas obligé ses sources et il
peut la loi le protège le journal c'est
protège
ce qui n'empêche pas la police dans le
cadre d'une réquisition du parquet de
tenter d'obtenir les images susceptibles
de pouvoir faire avancer une enquête
c'est vrai que moi flic de toute façon
si j'ai besoin d'images je ferai une
réquisition
la chaîne de télé ou site internet qui a
diffusé des images dont éventuels qui
pourraient éventuellement servir à
l'enquête ensuite la réponse il a pas
réponse alors s'il y a pas réponse
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ce qu'on va faire
une perquisition
dans les locaux de la chaîne de télé ou
canards enchaînés ou je sais pas où pour
obtenir ce qu'on ne veut pas nous donner
là c'est la perquisition c'est pas bon
si le journal qui soit au presse écrite
presse télévisé enfin peu importe veux
pas donner les images
à la différence du secret professionnel
qui est une obligation pour certaines
professions le journaliste a le choix de
divulguer ou non c'est source
lorsque vous ne voulez pas révéler vos
sources vous pouvez ne serait-ce que par
une possibilité matérielle de dire
l'erreur sont détruits le nom de ce
monsieur je ne m'en souviens pas
l'adresse de ce monsieur je ne m'en
souviens pas et c'est au moins une
possibilité qui vous est offerte pour
voilà pouvoir continuer à travailler en
toute en toute indépendance et en toute
confiance
pour Richard Malka avocat spécialiste du
droit de la presse la loi du 4 janvier
2010 qui renforce le principe de la
protection des sources offre
journalistes de véritables garanties
mille fois des policiers sont venus
demander des rushs à des journalistes
que je défendais systématiquement la
réponse est non faites votre travail
nous on a fait notre si à partir de
notre enquête qui a été diffusée vous
pensez qu'il y a des infractions vous
voulez faire votre propre enquête
allez-y mais nous on a fait votre
travail on a rien à vous fournir de plus
mais le mardi 6 avril Laurent Richard de
l'agence Kappa signal aux autorités 23
pédophiles présumés sur lesquels il
enquêtait pour le magazine Les Infiltrés
le débat sur la protection des sources
et relancer
bien sûr qu'elle se crée des sources ce
serait des sources il est important on a
tous été confrontés ici à cette question
là un jour ou des policiers ne
demandaient source on les a tous refusés
ça va de soi capable moi on n'est pas
contre le secret des sources on n'est
pas on n'est pas comme ça mais c'est pas
là on parle pas de source on parle de
gens qu'on a découvert au cours d'un
reportage sur leur mode opératoire c'est
pas des gens qui ont signé qu'on tapé
dans ma main et qui m'ont dit je te
donne cette information là tu me
garantis mon animal et tu verras tu
pourras avancer sur ton enquête ça
marche pas comme ça c'est pas une source
le secret des sources devrait-il alors
être posé comme un dogme absolu une
règle qui interdirait au journaliste de
révéler des informations qu'il considère
préjudiciables à l'ordre public
il n'était pas question de laisser
violer des enfants au nom d'une charte
au nom d'un secret des sources à propos
de source qui n'en sont pas il n'était
pas question de vivre les carences ou
cinquante années qui me restent avec sur
ma conscience le viol d'un ou de
plusieurs enfants ou la mort de
plusieurs enfants c'était pas question
peut-on dès lors considérer que cette
démarche de signalement à la police
après enquête est une dérive en arguant
de morale plutôt que d’informations le
journaliste a-t-il ouvert une brèche qui
mène à la délation
est-ce qu'un journaliste qui signait la
des policiers des pédophiles
actuellement en train d'abuser d'enfants
ce est un auxiliaire de police moi je
poserai une autre question est-ce qu'en
journaliste qui se saurait tu sur les
agissements criminels qui consistait à
violer des enfants pour être condamné
pour complicité de crimes sur un enfant
c'est ça c'est une autre question voilà
la meilleure réponse que j'ai à faire
accapa c'est que
il ne trouveront aucun exemple dans
l'histoire de ce pays d'un journaliste
qui aurait été poursuivi et condamné
parce qu'il n'aurait pas dénoncé à la
police telle ou telle personne qui
l'aurait interviewé
alors le journaliste doit-il être
considéré comme un citoyen lambda que la
loi oblige par ailleurs à dénoncer des
agissements criminels ou comme un
professionnel tenu au secret par sa
déontologie carte de presse ou carte de
police il faut choisir
que vous ayez une carte de presse ou pas
que vous soyez un voisin de cet homme-là
ou que vous soyez un journaliste qui a
connaissance de ça c'est à peu près la
même chose c'est même pas tellement la
le journaliste c'est le c'est le citoyen
j'allais même dire c'est l'humain vous
arrivez à aider à sauver des enfants et
vous vous posez plus tellement la
question de la déontologie de la carte
de presse ou je ne sais pas quoi vous
êtes juste un homme qui vient aider des
autres sommes et en l'occurrence des
enfants quand on est avocat quand on est
médecin quand on est journaliste on
n'est pas simple citoyen on a des droits
supplémentaires mais ces droits là vous
donnent des devoirs supplémentaires à
partir du moment où vous êtes un
professionnel alors il n'y a pas que la
bonne conscience qui compte alors il y a
vos devoirs professionnels qui sont plus
importants que cela parce que derrière
ces principes là il y a la confiance que
l'on peut avoir dans la profession de
journalistes et donc derrière le bon
fonctionnement d'une démocratie personne
n'aurait à gagner à ce que pour chacun
le journalisme puisse se transformer en
et en policiers
le problème est complexe de logique
s'affrontent obligation légale contre
obligation morale la déontologie
journalistique exonère-t-elle du devoir
de citoyen faut-il dénoncer ou pas si
oui ou placer le curseur un débat
caractère philosophique
est-ce qu'il y a un intérêt général
supérieur
qui est de montrer une réalité tout en
protégeant les sources pour pas
atteindre la relation de confiance qui
doit exister entre le journaliste et la
société qui est essentielle surtout
aujourd'hui et de plus en plus
C'est ça la vraie question c'est un
débat presque philosophique tout à fait
on a envie de dire oui il y a un intérêt
supérieur qui est celui
de protéger
l'accrédibilité d'un métier le lien de
confiance qu'il y a entre une presse des
médias indépendants
et totalement indépendant et totalement
honnête dans leur démarche et la société
on a envie de dire oui
bien sûr et on défend ça c'est plus
facile là de le dire comme ça
c'est un drôle que vous me donnez après
dans la dans la réalité quand on enquête
sur un truc de terrorisme et qu'on se
retrouve avec des des vrais terroristes
et qu'on sait qui vont peut-être poser
une bombe ou des pédophiles qui si vous
voulez qu'on fasse je ne sais pas moi je
ne suis jamais retrouvé dans ces
situations là ce coup de canif a fait du
mal à cette profession en même temps je
dois reconnaître que peut-être il a
aussi fait du bien parce qu'il a
provoqué un débat intéressant
assez profond la polémique a été parfois
virulente mais assez passionnante en
même temps je pense que si ça a aidé à
faire réfléchir
sur ce qu'est le métier de journaliste
c'est déjà une bonne chose
je t'aime moi non plus c'est un peu ce
qui caractérise en France les rapports
du trio télévisions police
justice aujourd'hui on préfère parler de
télécitoyenne ou téléservices personne
n'ose plus prononcer les mots de télé
flics comme dans les années 90
la télévision ne serait plus un
auxiliaire de police mais juste un outil
au service de la justice bref beaucoup
de chemin a été parcourus la cote de
l'appel à témoin est considérablement
remontée les barricades à ne pas
franchir sont clairement établis alors
parmi tous les rôles qu'incarnent la
télévision celui de faire oeuvre
citoyenne à sans aucun doute un bel
avenir devant lui
[Musique]